the second thing i learned is that
there's an immense amount of fear
driving all of this
i said that so many of the people i
encountered on the street appeared to be
confused
some of them actually were confused
one woman was particularly committed to
the relativistic view that we all have
our own truth
and i asked her um
well okay we all have our own truth what
would happen if if it was my truth
that you don't exist
and she looked me dead in the eyes and
she said that if i think she doesn't
exist
then she doesn't exist
and she was not joking
now i knew that women were being erased
in our culture that's part of the reason
i made the movie i didn't realize that
some women were so eager to erase
themselves
but more often i encountered people
whose confusion was more of a it was
more of a front it was it was an
affectation
they gave vague and dodgy answers to my
questions because they were afraid to
speak basic biological truths on camera
many refuse to say anything at all
telling me that if they that if they uh
you know if they talk about this issue
with the cameras rolling that it would
mean the loss of their job their friends
their family their reputation
to be clear their lives would be
destroyed if they said something like
only women can have babies
on camera
or any similarly provocative statement
gender ideology paves the way for itself
through fear
with intimidation
threats coercion